autre terrière invité ce soir le nouveau
mec de richard berry jean reno
à l'an dernier richard g qui veut nous
parler de votre pièce nous femmes avec
daniel auteuil cette année c'est jean
reno vous les préférez du muscle et ça
l'émission s'appelle salut hitlérien le
robot s'appelle jean me et le groupe est
vraiment fortiche
[Musique]
à
j'aurai les jambes et rêva bonsoir vous
êtes ici ce soir pour nos femmes la
pièce d'eric assous que vous reprenez au
théâtre de paris toujours dans une mise
en scène de richard berry vous remplacer
daniel auteuil et jean vous remplace
c'est ça la différence c'est que quand
vous parlez à reno vous êtes juste
obligé de lever un peu plus la terre un
petit peu plus la tête mais ça apporte
quelque chose d'assez drôle dans la
pièce je pense arriver vous parle de
biopsie de djezzy alors que daniel
auteuil nous parler de dave
c'est vrai moi j'ai bien aimé rencontrer
d'ailleurs ouais il est venu plusieurs
fois dans les coulisses des films elle
rencontre 60 vous avez une fille de
trois mois qui crient tous les soirs
c'est pour ça que vous vous avez repris
la pièce non non parce qu'elle fait ses
nuits comment elle s'appelle milla quel
joli prenait
en tout cas je suis très heureux de vous
recevoir tous les deux richard vous
savez je suis fan de bouger tous vos
disques heureusement y avait quand même
les gens vous c'est la première fois que
que je vous reçois dans l'une de mes
émissions lors comme c'est la première
fois on fera un focus sur vous en
deuxième partie d'accord mais revenons
la pièce d'eric assous donc mise en
scène de richard berry au théâtre de
paris à partir du 3 février on regarde
le teaser la question qui se pose c'est
est ce qu'on fait pour un ami c'est
plutôt jusqu'où on peut aller pour alami
braver la justice web et la morale le
problème c'est qu'on était de décider et
quand il y en a deux qui décident s'ils
sont pas d'accord c'est difficile c'est
à celui qui va être les plus
convaincants donc discussions débats
polémiques controverse bras de fer il ya
des jours comme ça où plutôt de nuit
parce que c'était la nuit ah les femmes
nos femmes nos
fins le plus c'est super ça est super
fort vous êtes deux amis deux médecins
et chérie chat vous attendez un ami qui
est coiffeur braoudé qui arrivent en
retard et quand ils arrivent ils vous
apprend qu'il vient de tuer sa femme
alors que faire est ce qu'il faut le
dénoncer ce qu'il faut l'aider c'est
sujet de la pièce l'un considère pas ce
que c'est celui de joue maintenant j'en
qu' il faut être dans la vie normale
dans la loi dans la justice est donc
scellé dès que de l'encourager à se
dénoncer en tueur et l'autre que je joue
maintenant pense qu'il faudrait quand
même essayer de le couvrir et puis des
événements qui vont petit à petit
intervenir dans le débat vont faire que
bah ça va changer de point de vue alors
j'en faisais mais beaucoup de terre dit
il ya une solidarité entre comédiens les
vibrations du public rien ne peut
remplacer ça oui bien sûr cette chose
qui est cette unité comme ça pendant
deux heures ce groupe de gens ensemble
ouais la salle la scène les coulisses
aussi tout ça est très important est-ce
que vous avez présenté votre ami biopsie
à harry chambéry benchenni jenny jezzine
on n'a pas eu le temps j'ai rencontré
lenny kravitz en revanche voilà
mais c'est pas exactement mon tipi
trois fans il connaît toutes les
chorégraphies de beyoncé parker il
s'entraîne deux jours là c'est même sur
7 bien sûr oui c'est vrai alors j'ai
tourné le film aussi oui il sort qu'on
le filme le 29 avril et on vous avez
passé votre vie sur salut les terriens
en cette année vous j'espère bien parce
que je fais tout ça pour passer sur
salut les terriens sur entre provins
alors on va rester dans le cinéma avec
un blindtest musique de film avec jean
mi attention tout le monde joue
[Musique]
attention
je veux le titre du film
[Musique]
et pourtant quand on chante
[Applaudissements]
j'en crois que
je chante comme une casserole
allons-y journée
[Musique]
attin année tout ça me prend bon
jeu
des ballots la blague
si je le trouvais corbin basij en y
[Musique]
échapper
toutefois
jean louis
[Applaudissements]
l'inique tu vas y croire
attention gens me plaît
ania
là
ces anciennes galeries alors ça c'est
pas un jean mi
attention janvier
[Applaudissements]
dans la mer
ou pas
j'en ai
gagné
là les filles ont gagné bravo à mort
[Musique]
m
alors jean regnaud richard berry
revanche cela c'est donc ici ce soir
pour la pièce nos femmes d'eric assous
mise en scène de richard berry au
théâtre de paris à partir du 3 février
et tout ça me permet d'enfin avoir sur
mon plateau jean reno pourquoi n'êtes
vous jamais venu dans une de mes
émissions auparavant je ne sais pas je
me souviens plus j'ai je vous fais peur
non pas du tout gentil mais vous êtes
gentils vous est costaud de façon non je
ne sais pas 2 j'ai vachement insisté
merci
c'est dommage parce que j'admire
beaucoup en fait un mac a débuté sa
carrière dans les bidasses aux grandes
manoeuvres avec paul préboist et michel
galabru et qui a fini par faire mission
impossible avec tom cruise ronin avec
robert de niro ou le davinci code avec
tom hanks ce américain triomphe quand
même merde
[Musique]
alors vous êtes et ses lecteurs français
parfaitement mondialisée un espagnol né
au maroc devenu une star au japon en
jouant un apnéiste italien exactement
j'ai vécu toute ma vie dans une valise
voilà alors vous êtes né le 30 juillet
1948 à casablanca deux parents andalou
ayant fui l'espagne de franco votre vrai
nom c'est don juan moreno et l'airé
jiménez c'est vrai que pour devenir 0
c'est un nom super
lourd été pris il ya un an et revenir un
acteur français c'est un peu plus
compliqué il avait choisi jean reno
alain delon ou jean gabin c'est beaucoup
plus simple tout le monde s'en souvient
oui vous avez eu heureusement leur
enfance difficile en arrivant au maroc
votre père vendait des cheveux
avant ma naissance alors après il était
boulanger ça c'est vrai il dormait dans
des sacs de farine ça c'est vrai et
après il a été linotypiste aux petits
marocains linotypiste et les gens qui
mettent les et les gens qui tapent pour
avoir la ligne à l'envers pour pouvoir
imprimer aux et dur quand même oui c'est
un ouvrier j ai pas de blé quoi on était
pas deux nuls pied ouais mais on n'était
pas riche mais a été couturière elle
fabriquait des manteaux mais démentent
au maroc ça devait pas est une affaire
très florissante je félicite et je suis
assez mois d'octobre il y avait d'un peu
de pluie je pense que c'est ça il était
7 heures du soir et des flashs comme ça
et aujourd'hui vous êtes pote avec jay-z
et beyoncé quel parcours jean reno
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est par le biais de ma femme ouais
les pieds là au départ de djezzy quand
j'hésite sort de sa banlieue alors quand
bien aussi vient dîner chez vous est-ce
que vous lui mettez deux chaises pour
qu'elle pose ses cuisses
de 2,2 non ne soyons pas méchants vous
avez vu sur tour de chant ouais un jour
je l' ai vu je suis tomber du fauteuil
ah ouais à cause de ces cui
alors vous êtes pote avec djezzy nicolas
sarkozy y en a un des deux qui voulait
absolument que vous lui présentiez
l'autre c'est le qu est
la réponse est facile c'est lesquels le
plus bas bailly jazzy enfer cosy
je vais garder ça pour moi
alors sarkozy était votre témoin de
mariage est ce que vous serez témoins à
son procès jean
peut-être on ne sait jamais de quoi la
vie ça fait
alors
parallèlement aux visiteurs 3
expendables 4 est ce que vous allez
jouer dans sarko 2 la revanche j'ai du
mal de parler de mes opinions politiques
en public ouais enfin vous êtes affiché
que sarkozy quand même oui mais parce
que par amitié ben oui oui ce serait
politiquement vous n'êtes pas d'accord
voilà c'est comme la pour moi c'est
comme la religion c'est quelque chose
qui est privé quelle histoire que votre
vie le petit andalou qui découvre sa
vocation à l'âge de 12 ans en jouant les
précieuses ridicules et qui va devenir
une star à hollywood est un demi-dieu au
japon c'est vous parce que vous êtes
bien renseigné ouais ça vient de loin
quand même temps 12 à la vérité puisque
je suis là pour une pièce de théâtre ça
vient d'eux des coulisses du théâtre de
des sons des odeurs de cette ambiance
qu'il ya entre les loges et la scène de
le bois le lait sont encore une fois les
odeurs le bruissement des étoffes la
loge des femmes gressard et pour moi
était à plein de promesses quoi plein de
il fallait aller là à être déçu que moi
tu pourras béthune
d'autres
avaient beaucoup de succès au japon mais
surtout avec les femmes mais il paraît
que la première phrase que vous avez su
dire en japonais c'est non ce bébé n'est
pas de moi
il ya une autre phrase que vous avez
apprise très rapidement aussi c'est
bonjour il est où le chèque pour la pub
n'est qu'en rire ligne de vos pubs au
japon mais le voici en savoie on va
tâcher sentiments
[Musique]
alors
ça veut dire toi de quoi est il question
dans cette publicité il faut dire que ça
fait à peu près dix sept ans que je
travaille au japon uniquement pour
toyota et donc il ya eu une évolution
sur mon personnage on m'a groupe est là
avec un chat un chat qui est qui et qui
guide la jeunesse à chaque fois qu'il ya
des problèmes et ils ont pris ce ça ils
vont poser la question du genre est ce
que toi il ya que toi qui peux faire un
chat mais évidemment et alors j'ai dit
c'est c'est eh oui la pâtée et dont on
m'a montré une boîte de pâté c'est comme
ça j'ai commencé
très précises dont jean reno
j'ai l'impression d'être un mec très
très solide pourtant après le grand bleu
avec un succès phénoménal vous n'avez
pas su gérer votre célébrité oui la
pression du succès étaient trop fortes
vous avez pété les plombs vous dites
j'étais gaver de voyages d'hôtel
d'argent de manas oui et d'ailleurs mon
couple a explosé avant le succès lorsque
vous parlez
tout le monde ne détournent la tête où
on va regarder quelqu'un d'autre après
le succès dès que vous aurez la bouche
tout le monde écoute ouais qu'est ce qui
dit ouais c'est tellement formidable ce
qu'il dit qu'est-ce qu'il est beau voilà
et ça il faut le digérer il faut
apprendre le digérer et revenir sur
terre est oublié et essayez pas de
redevenir totalement anonyme mais
essayer de retrouver cette humanité qui
a fait que vous êtes à cet endroit là
j'espère que je suis claire très clair
merci c'est mieux que la publ un réseau
alors
évidemment les succès du grand bleu
était phénoménale la rencontre avec
besson c'était sur ce fameux film les
bidasses aux grandes manoeuvres avec
paul préboist peuple et michel galabru
et lui il était donc besson assistant
réalisateur de raphaël delpard
évidemment inoubliable un réalisateur de
films et lorsqu'elle très marrant c'est
que le matin vous arrivés tous les deux
super en avance et moi je suis j'arrive
avant lui encore avant lui il supporte
pas ça j'étais devenu complice qua non
il m'a regardé c'était pas complices il
m'a regardée ouais et s'il dit cela ça
peut ne pas être mal hein c'est comme ça
que ça commençait à ce qui est très
marrant en fait c'est que vous avez
tourné avec les plus grands réalisateurs
du monde aimé le film déterminant dans
notre carrière c'est les bidasses aux
grandes manoeuvres
quelque part oui bien joué bien entendu
c'est un avec elle sans jamais y vit
après j'ai fait les salades ça a évolué
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu